[Applause]
they called saturday d-day when
protesters say the president and his
government would be forced to step down
they blame kotabaya rajapaksa for an
economic crisis that's made life
unbearable for many of the country's 22
million people
[Applause]
after breaking through barricades yet
another unprecedented moment the
demonstrator stormed into the
president's official residence in
colombo
[Applause]
inside this is what it looked like
the president was moved by his security
team to an undisclosed location earlier
while protesters ransacked his bedroom
and took photographs on his bed
within moments the presidential pool
once reserved for the country's top
leaders
appeared more like a community pool
today is the independence day for me
been born in this nation not 1948
because today
we have fought for our freedom
from the tyranny
from the scoundrels
from the gods
from the rascals the rogues
and the greedy politicians who have run
our nation below
ground zero
the 73 year old president was elected in
2019
analysts say it's only a matter of time
before he's forced to step down
as soon as the president's resignation
is announced the prime minister becomes
the acting president according to the
constitution and that is for a period of
30 days within which parliament must
decide who amongst its members will be
elected to serve the remainder of gotham
raj pakistan
anger is rising at the government's
handling of a dire economic crisis the
worst in 70 years
the monthly minimum wage is about 80
dollars and access to food fuel and
medicine is limited and the government
has run out of foreign currency
rajapaksa's political allies know this
is a crucial moment for his presidency
because they want not only the president
to go they want the prime minister to go
they want the government to go it is
very ironic you know that this is a
government that came to power on the
basis of nationalism on the basis of the
ethnic majority nationalism they have
been pushed out now
smaller demonstrations held earlier this
year had little impact
now the frustration appears to have
turned into a movement that can no
longer be ignored
katya lopez al jazeera
and manel fernandez reports from colombo
president gotaber rajapaksa and his
government had been put on notice that
if he didn't go that the whole of sri
lanka would take to the streets that
would come and basically sit in until
they saw his exit as you can see behind
me the crowd i mean essentially in the
far distance the presidential
secretariat but tens of thousands of
people still streaming in to colombo in
any way they can on our drive here we
saw dozens of people on foot with
backpacks living around colombo even
people who had been walking from out of
colombo we're also hearing that trains
which had been
sort of halted uh people stormed railway
stations and literally forced railway
employees to put trains on the tracks
and bring them into colombo and the one
thing they say that they are taking
their country back
today is the independence day for me
been born in this nation not 1948
because today
we have fought for our freedom
from the tyranny
from the scoundrels
from the gods from the rascals the
rogues
and the greedy politicians who have run
our nation
below
ground zero
and this is exactly what the government
tried so hard to prevent the thousands
of people converging on the capital to
urge the president and his government to
go they brought in a curfew they had to
remove it the next day they essentially
wanted the distribution of fuel whatever
little stocks were available were frozen
uh essentially transport public
transport was stopped but people were
not giving up and if you look at the far
background the sri lankan flag flying
high the rajapaksa regime the government
of gotham rajapaksa and his brother
president mahinda rajapaksa were so sort
of keen and strong to talk about
nationalism but the people here say this
is the true spirit of sri lankans and
they want their country back
and manell fernandez joins us live now
on the phone hello there manell so the
prime minister says he's willing to
stand down what else came out of that
meeting of party leaders
so from my sources i hear that with
quite a lot of animated discussion uh
one of the things uh that had been
discussed was the go the go gota
campaign uh and essentially calls for
gotabay rajapaksa the president to step
down came up but the party leaders had
pointed out that given the national
outcry that people would not be
satisfied and they had pushed for even
more
essentially to be done they had
recommended that both the president and
the prime minister both stepped down now
this didn't
go down very well there were some
discussions uh at which point we're also
hearing from the prime minister's office
that the prime minister uh basically
offered to step down saying he was
willing to resign
only when there was a national
government that was put in place uh so
as to ensure that the stability the sort
of bin building blocks back to normality
if you like is not sort of hampered by
political instability now that's not
obviously uh to say how much instability
all of this is causing but
again obviously the prime minister uh
having said that uh he is willing to go
but obviously with some strong caveats
so the party leaders uh must now
sort of discuss among themselves in
terms of the formation of a national
government and that's where things stand
at the moment
now despite what the leaders have agreed
on will that actually be enough for
protesters
well one of the things the protesters
have said and we heard this uh sort of
repeated again and again out on the
streets of colombo today
is that they're not going to be
shortchanged they're not going to be
hoodwinked any longer so as much as this
campaign has been waged for over three
months where they've been urging the
president then the prime minister to go
home
and even when
the prime minister at the time of
mahinda rajapaksa who is the president's
elder brother
finally accepted uh the cause to resign
and went people were still saying that
is not enough
so they kept pushing they weren't happy
obviously with prime minister iran
vikrama singha someone who had been
voted out of parliament unable to secure
his own seat and now the people
are very very clear they say if this
does not pan out as we have asked and if
this is all a sort of an attempt to pull
wool over their eyes um
they're not going to hesitate in
marching on colombo again it almost
seems that there is a certain political
awakening
there is a certain awareness among the
people that they have kind of put a full
stop uh just to being sort of hoodwinked
and strung along by their political
leadership so
as much as you might find prime minister
rana vikrama singh a very astute uh
politician over many many decades
you know playing word game saying he's
willing to resign but you know having uh
sort of caveats on that about you know
the formation of a national government
before he does so a people's um
tolerance levels have pretty much
reached um zero points so they are
obviously going to watch they're going
to see what happens and they're going to
actually push again if what they have
been demanding does not come to fruition
you've spent most of the day out on the
streets among the protesters what's been
the mood
with demonstrators i mean we're seeing
various scenes some of them partying in
a pool and then others on the street
being fired with tear gas can you talk
us through the makeup of the group
yeah it's it's so it's all being sort of
unfolding throughout the day today as
you said uh the morning was quite tense
because it began with people converging
on colombo this mind you despite a host
of government attempts to prevent that
gathering uh from curfew to stopping the
issue of fuel to a lot of intimidation
but people came and then there was a
standoff in terms of some entrance
points or access points to that
president's official residence but
basically that first volley of tear gas
that then followed with a number of
rounds of tear gas this morning in fact
the al jazeera team came in for it as
well and it believe me it's it's not a
pleasant experience um hundreds and
hundreds of students uh were basically
um affected uh this happened actually
when there wasn't a whole
sort of you know attempt at violence uh
the police just pushed the line back
obviously very keen to make sure that
the protesters don't uh break through
the barricades and enter the president's
house ultimately it came to nothing
because as you can see those pictures in
the pool uh all of those protesters just
enjoying the fact that they had breached
uh the president's uh sort of security
and done what they said they would do
that they would take the fight right to
the president and make him go and it
that is exactly what happened in terms
of at least physically he had to be
whisked away under escort uh as he fled
the oncoming protesters now there was a
lot of anger among the protesters lots
of young people a real mix of um sort of
protesters coming out and it's quite
amazing in terms of the way they found
their way to colombo given that there
was no public transport most problem
people had problems with fuel i mean
they came in vehicle carriers in lorries
on bicycle on foot there was one old
lady a grandmother with her two
grandchildren who had walked over 20
kilometers the poor lady was almost at
the point of exhaustion and she sort of
fainted by the side of the road and had
to be revived so there were lots of
people these aren't just kind of rebel
young people trying to cause mayhem this
was people from all walks of life across
the rainbow of sri lanka that had come
to you know put
their sort of full stop on the rajapaksa
regime and the government that has
basically brought sri lanka to its knees
certainly a dynamic situation we really
appreciate you giving us that update
minelle fernandez live for us in colombo
thank you
let's take a closer look now at the
rajapaksa family which has dominated
politics in sri lanka for 20 years
mahinda rajapaksa the current
president's brother came to power as
president in 2005 and led the country
for 10 years he appointed his three
brothers as government ministers gotta
buy rajapaksa won the presidency in 2019
and immediately appointed his brother
mahinda as prime minister mahinda was
replaced by renewal vika ramasingha in
may
demonstrators accuse the brothers of
cronyism corruption and economic
policies that have caused the current
crisis
for more on this story let's bring in
w.a widja
denna who is an independent economic
analysis analyst rather and the former
deputy governor of the central bank of
sri lanka he joins us from colombo wa
thanks so much for being on the program
as we've been reporting the sri lankan
prime minister says he's willing to
resign to make way for an all-party
government
will this ease protesters concerns
well of course you know whatever the
promises made by
prime minister raj vikram singh
should be taken with a pinch of salt
because he had been
famous for
uh breaking his promises in the past
so i feel that you know unless he
resigns and you know goes away
the protest campaign will continue and
it might end up in a bloodbath
not like the peaceful protest that had
taken place in sri lanka right now it
might end up in a bloodbath so to avoid
that bloodbath my view is that he should
immediately step down and allow the
party leaders to elect their own
government right now
we haven't actually seen or heard from
the president today
what is the alternative to a roger
pakistan government
well in terms of the constitution and
has agreed by the party leaders who have
met the speaker
they can actually appoint the speaker of
parliament as the interim president but
he has to win a lot of confidence in
parliament which is simply a simple
majority which is not difficult task for
him to get
and then he will have to ask another np
to form a government and that government
we have to carry on for six months uh
providing relief to the members of the
public and putting laying down the basic
requirements to
to
to eliminate the current economic crisis
and also to enable the country to have
another general election after six
months time
which would enable the country to elect
its own government so this is the
timeline and the strategy that is being
proposed by many people who have been
engaged in the protest campaign now
the thing is though even if the
government is replaced there's no
short-term solution to fix the economic
woes of sri lanka is there and sri
lankans are really facing fuel and food
shortages for some time yet
well you are perfectly correct
simply because we have an interim
government
of all political parties doesn't mean
that sri lanka would be able to resolve
all the acute economic issues that we
are facing today
specifically we don't have any foreign
exchange with the central bank of sri
lanka and as a result sri lanka is
unable to maintain the minimum import
program
which includes the importation of fuel
cooking gas
medicines food items
inputs for industries and so forth so
there will be a very difficult time
period for sri lankans in the next two
to three months time period
but what it means is that given the
complexity and the acuteness of the
current economic crisis
my guess is that all of us will have to
make the supreme sacrifice
we'll have to
actually change our present modern
lifestyles we have to change we have to
become you know very altruistic people
in the country we have to work for
nothing so likewise lots of demands are
to be made of the people in sri lanka
to enable the country to come out of the
present crisis
you're in colombo at the moment what's
it like personally living there how can
you carry out your daily tasks are you
able to go to the petrol station are you
able to get the food that you need
well of course i stood in the petrol
cave for four days
in order to get a percent experience of
you know what it feels like
three days it was in vain because the
bosses didn't come with petrol on the
fourth day i put my vehicle to the queue
at three o'clock in the morning but the
bowser came only at nine o'clock in the
night and by the time i went home it was
around 11 o'clock but i had lots of
experience with the people who stood
there in the cube and the agony and the
difficulties that these people are going
through i actually experienced myself
right now i don't use my car because i
was given only a 10 to 20 liters of
petrol which is not sufficient for me to
use my car i have kept it as a reserve
for an emergency i either walk or use
public transport whenever they are
available to move from one place to
another now these are the type of life
that we are living in sri lanka today in
color
well we really appreciate your insights
thank you very much wa wiji wadena an
independent economic analyst thank you
for your time